Good morning Hank, it’s Tuesday.
I wake up every morning, with a few hours of sleep
with “Five Hundred Miles” stuck in my head.
🎶When I wake up, will you know I’m gonna have this freaking song in my head🎶
I pack up, head out to the van that I still cannot believe exists,
and then drive fife hundred miles or whatever,
to the next place.
The van is very comfortable, and we have neck pillows,
but it’s impossible to sleep in there,
Because one, it’s not a bed, and two,
there is an Xbox, and so all we ever do is beat the holey living crap out of each other’s pixels.
We arrive early afternoon
and find lots of books needing signatures and Hanklerfishes, which takes a couple hours.
Although, fortunately, I have a fair bit of experience in the field of signing my name,
and Hank, I’d wager that you've drawn more anglerfishes than anyone alive on the planet.
And before you tell me that the plural of anglerfish is anglerfish,
Wikipedia it!
Then the people start to show up and there are a lot of them.
They wore my face on their torso, or Doctor Who shirts,
and they bring book cakes
and they have things I wrote tattooed on their bodies.
Sometimes in borderline inappropriate places.
All of which is amazing and beautiful
and also, of course, completely terrifying.
Whispers: I’m nervous
Then we have a quick meeting with Hank Sock.
Hank Sock: Hello, this is Hank Sock.
Back stage, for the show. A little nervous, but uh,
a lot of people out there. I can see ‘em through the crack in the curtain.
Back to Narration: And it’s time to start the show.
Hank, writing is something you do alone. It’s a profession for introvers
who want to tell you a story but don’t want to make eye contact while telling it.
And on some level, writing is the exact opposite
of this.
*Croud screming in delight*
Then I read, and talk about The Fault in Our Stars,
and you sing some songs,
I answer some questions,
you wear a tutu,
we answered questions together and whoever is talking when the timer goes off
gets shocked with the Charlie is So CoolLike patented Shocker.
*Hank gets shocked, crown cheers*
Then you sing some more songs, and people dance, and it feels magical
and otherworldly to be in a room full of people who feel unembarrassed
of their enthusiasm and intellect.
🎶Hank sings🎶
And then we sign for five hours. Which I won’t show you much of
because the only thing more boring than standing in line,
is watching other people stand in line.
Then we get to the hotel around 2 am, I sleep for a few hours
and wake up with “Five Hundred Miles” in my head, grateful
and astonished.
To have the readers,
and the brother
I’ve lucked into.
Hank, I’ll see you on Friday.